[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
BMW presents the seventh generation of
it's five series the business class
bestseller has various new developments
to offer its aerodynamics have been
enhanced and that means more power with
lower fuel consumption and what customer
wouldn't like that we test-drove the
540i with a sizable 3 liter engine
the core of the brand in many respects
is the 5 Series in the 3 Series and of
course the 5 series has got great
history back from 1972 or dare I say 44
years ago this car really did create a
segment that has become synonymous with
the core of BMW you see the brand being
shaped from the top you know 7 Series
the i8 but if you asked a lot of
customers they see this car as one which
really stands for everything BMW is
positioned for it's an icon with plenty
of power the standard 6-cylinder engine
produces 250 kilowatts for a top speed
of 250 kilometers an hour
the new model Sprint's from zero to a
hundred and five point one seconds
prices start at fifty seven thousand
seven hundred euros in Germany
rear-wheel drive makes this agile car
live up to BMW slogan the ultimate
driving machine
as core reviewer Montes points out that
German mid class sedan segment includes
the BMW 5-series the Audi a6 and the
Mercedes e-class the BMW has always been
regarded as the sportiest of the three
brands with this standard fitted drive
mode switch Motta's can choose between
sport and comfort and if the car has the
optionally available adaptive suspension
the sport mode gives you a stiffer ride
so you can take curves extremely fast
sport gear on done
conman deals altavista schnell on the
kovin Bovina visually the 5 series looks
like it's Big Brother the 7 Series
that's due to the kidney grilles in
front which join up with the headlights
and give the fine series a much broader
look the M Sport package cost in an
additional four thousand six hundred
euros comprises a range of technical and
styling extras
[Music]
[Music]
isn't tomorrow due kick had a BMWs
exterior design division explains the
changes to the five series front the
hood now fits directly onto the upper
edge of the kidney grilles and
headlights it's a manifestation of
greater precision and attention to
detail with the kidneys being curved the
twin grilles a trademark of every BMW
have been made noticeably larger and BMW
has revived its old connection between
the grilles in the headlights which
makes the car look broader early BMWs
also at the grills and headlights in one
connected strip the noise info button
under some V here by the auto v rocker
shaft high-class and high performance
the interior features quality materials
the interior has changed a lot from the
predecessor it's now more dynamic and
less cluttered the Bowers & Wilkins
surround sound system is 1,400 watts of
power with 16 loudspeakers transforming
the 5-series into a concert hall on
wheels
let's get gun montes points out another
feature he loves in this car when you
activate the parking sensors you first
get the bird's-eye view camera which you
can find in many models these days but
you can also adjust the view to get the
image of the car from any perspective
monthís can size up the parking spot and
see whether he can open the doors wide
enough Wow
my father Montes sums up his impressions
the BMW 5-series is a beautiful vehicle
but beauty comes at a price and so this
car will probably first serve as a
leased company car when it's done that
for three years a regular car buyer will
be able to afford it used all classes
yet
[Music]
many people in Europe associate
Mitsubishi with either cheap small cars
a robust SUVs we're taking one of its
crossover models out for a spin the
Outlander explains our car man Sasha is
one of the most popular SUVs in the
world
and Germany is still just a niche
product but the 2017 edition could
change that Quinta das soma and bits in
Vita keulegan and Europe the Outlander
comes with a choice of two engines a 2.2
litre diesel and a 2 liter gasoline unit
both are available with optional
all-wheel-drive Sacha is driving the
diesel version with all-wheel drive his
first impression is that while this
vehicle will get you through thick and
thin it won't do it very quickly it
slowed down by its weight and the top
equipment line with all-wheel drive some
117 kilos more than the entry version
with front-wheel drive the diesel
Edition needs 11.6 seconds to make the
dash to 100 kilometers an hour
top speed with a 6-speed automatic
transmission is just less than an
overwhelming 190 kilometers per hour
our kiss car is fitted with adaptive
all-wheel drive an eco mode the one axle
is deployed almost exclusively this does
theoretically allow you to meet the
manufacturers official fuel economy
rating of 5.8 liters per 100 kilometers
all-wheel drive only kicks in when the
wheels start to slip the most
outstanding change for Sasha the one
that no longer stands out is that the
rear antenna has been replaced by this
little shark fin the car is now a bit
more streamlined one change Sasha would
like to make and it's the same with most
car makers is the unbearably slow
opening trunk lid and winter you really
wish would open a bit faster but once
you've folded down all five rear seats
you have a flat cargo platform and a
total volume of 1613 litres and that's
nothing to sneeze at the third row of
seats is only available with the diesel
Edition gasoline engine buyers will have
to make do with five seats Sasha
appreciates the legroom in the back but
not the Headroom even with his short
hair he's touching the roof lining and
he's worried about getting it dirty
because he has a bit of gel in his hair
Sasha would have preferred this little
bulge here further forward so that he
would sit more comfortably but Simba
criminal's add some colour that bulge in
the restricted Headroom are due to the
glass sunroof the cabin is nice and
spacious and uncluttered
[Music]
there are new piano black accents
although your fingerprints show up
everywhere
the cup holder is now hidden away under
a special cover
[Music]
but the most important new feature in
the Outlander has to be the safety
package available for an extra one
thousand four hundred euros it includes
a blind spot alert that also warns the
driver of rear cross-traffic when
leaving a parking space it's especially
useful in the city not least because of
all those cyclists racing around
insulated windows help to keep out noise
the diesel engine does get a bit loud so
Sasha that's primarily due to the
automatic transmission which is pretty
harmonious but sometimes isn't sure what
to do so the engine revs higher than
necessary it's not finished so the in
cost at the same time it costs 2,000
euros extra and comes without an
automatic start/stop something that
Sasha can't quite comprehend
and all the Mitsubishi Outlander is a
solid enough vehicle having
all-wheel-drive available as a big
benefit in the winter or in the
mountains plus you have a lot of space
for the whole family and cargo it's real
strength is its price advantage over
German car makers even if the
workmanship loses a couple of points
here and there but that's it
[Music]
the Gulf seven gets an update the
outgoing 1.4 liter TSI is being replaced
with a 1.5 liter TSI Evo the
manufacturer claims of fuel saving of up
to 0.3 litres per 100 kilometers LED
lights exceed the old xenon headlights
an optional 9.2 inch touch display as a
gesture control feature at a
configurable home screen the asking
price in Germany just under 18,000 euros
Toyota presents the new generation of
the Prius plug-in hybrid technically
it's been given a major makeover
compared with the regular edition the
hybrid comes with a 1.8 liter gasoline
engine combined with two electric motors
the front and rear design see
considerable changes and not just
because of the socket the aim is to give
the model greater individuality prices
and Germany start at just over thirty
seven and a half thousand euros
[Music]
you'll die car tester and we
congratulate Sunday for capturing a
younger than average customer base in
Germany now he's going to try to find
out how they did it by test driving the
new eye 30 the car buyers average age
has been steadily rising for over 20
years now but Hyundai has bucked the
trend its customers are two years
younger than the German average making
it the envy of big rivals such as Toyota
opal and VW one of Hyundai's main
selling points for the i30
is a starting price of seventeen
thousand four hundred fifty euros
although you get the engine you pay for
just seventy four kilowatts of power
in addition to the basic models 1.4
liter aspirated engine Hyundai offers to
modern turbocharged gasoline units and
one diesel he's testing the 1.4 liter t
GDI what he finds especially
praiseworthy is that even though it's a
1.4 liter engine with a turbocharger
attached it's actually lighter than the
aspirated engine the same size the most
powerful engine with 103 kilowatts still
comes up a bit short compared to similar
models German and other manufacturers
offer engines with quite a bit more
power but Hyundai's already gearing up
for the challenge
[Music]
the NZ undies Marcus Rick says the i30
is the first model to get the N series
high-performance engine the basic
version will put out 250 horsepower with
a module available to take it up to 275
another version is planned for 2018 that
achieves 300 horsepower taking a Hyundai
on the road will be an emotional
experience on an Elliot the design is
likewise big on emotion with a styling
providing the car's primary appeal 2004
Andre the I 30s exterior design cuts a
decent figure he especially likes the
way the wider sloping front gives it
such a dynamic look 12 body colours
leave choice enough for any individual
touch
the Korean brand is the only car maker
to produce its own steel the proportion
of high tensile steels has been
increased of 53 percent in the interest
of safety and driving dynamics inside
the i30 could easily hold its own with a
VW Golf
[Music]
the cargo area holds just about 400
litres with the rear seats folded up at
present the i30 is a safe investment for
value conscious buyers and made even
safer by a five-year guarantee with
unlimited mileage
[Music]
Dondre points out that the Hyundai i30
offers a great many drivers assist
systems many of them standard equipment
where other car makers would only offer
them an additional cost there are the
lane-keeping assist and the active city
brake other comforts that are standard
include cruise control and air
conditioning beat some buy speed in
Temple Martin what Eddie Clemont Naga
the top-line equipment package with the
new 103 kilowatt gasoline engine and
7-speed dual-clutch transmission lists
at 28,000 350 euros in Germany about
what you'd pay for a similarly equipped
VW golf but without the generous
guarantee
[Music]
now truly centers filled laundering
concedes there are many factors that
work together to make Hyundai appealing
to both older and younger car buyers but
first among them is the price the entry
model high 30 starts at 17 thousand four
hundred fifty euros in Germany while the
top range version comes closer to thirty
thousand in the end cars that are
popular with the older buyers are quite
often just too expensive for the younger
set
[Music]
car tester Reinhold Dyson over asks why
wait to go electric when you can do it
now we'll have to wait till 2020 for the
VW ID now a concept car and even longer
for the buzz Electric VW Bus but we
generally don't need 400 kilometers
range maybe less will do nicely so today
we'll be testing the plug-in hybrid the
VW Passat GTE the Passat GTE has two
power plants a 1.4 liter gasoline engine
and an electric motor for a total system
capacity of 160 kilowatts and a maximum
torque of 400 Newton meters for driving
modes make the Passat energy-efficient
sporty or in-between
that gay tastes I don't explains the gte
always starts on electric drive so it
doesn't wake the neighbors and it can
glide meaning the engine uncouples from
the transmission so that the car can
coach down the highway for example
without using any electricity
VW rates average fuel consumption at 1.8
liters for 100 kilometers that figures
in the distance covered on electric
drive with both power trains working
together the GTE accelerates from zero
to 100 and 7.4 seconds reaching a
maximum speed of 225 kilometers per hour
[Music]
the plug-in hybrid passant requires deep
pockets the sedan was for forty four
thousand two hundred fifty euros in
germany the station wagon for a thousand
more that puts it at the upper end of
the Passat range alongside the most
powerful fully equipped versions the
interior makes no compromises everything
we've come to expect of a pissant
[Music]
final points out that the GTE range is
40 to 50 kilometers on a fully charged
battery it may not sound like much but
it's more than enough for 80 percent of
daily driving a normal European 220 volt
household outlet fully recharges the
battery in about 4 hours
according to VW the conventional
gasoline engine combined with electric
drive makes for a total range of some
1,100 kilometers so it's no disaster if
you can't find the time to recharge now
and then but the straightforward
charging process quickly becomes a habit
and takes optimal advantage of the
electric drive technology coming up
Rhino says the Passat GTE means the
future is now he can use it to commute
to work on electric drive only but he
still has to halt to power trains around
the gasoline engine and the electric
motor and it comes at a price even so
this plug-in hybrid says I'm moving
toward the future
[Music]
open the throttle our test writer
Christophe Bauer is negotiating the
mountain passes in northern Italy's
Fantino region he's riding a vintage
1930 dkw super sports 600
Christophe says the dkw has a long
tradition of making quality motorcycles
in 1919 they built the first auxilary
motor for a two-wheeled vehicle some
referred to it as a but warmer over the
next decade dkw grew into one of the
world's largest manufacturers of
motorcycles and this super sport is the
firm's crowning achievement it's
designed for long hauls at top speed he
the engine makes a distinctive chatter
it's actually a two-stroke motor with
600 cc's of displacement this is the
biggest and baddest cycle that dkw ever
built
[Music]
Christophe says that at the beginning of
the 1930s the dkw Supersport was the
fastest bike around 22 horsepower in a
top speed of 100 km/h with a sidecar but
the sidecar could take some getting used
to if you went into a fast curve on the
left it could lift off so you had to
keep calm and not try to steer too hard
against it otherwise you'd end up in the
opposite lane and if you went too fast
into a curve on the right the cycle
itself could flip over the nose of the
sidecar
these @d covey Christophe says that
there was nothing else like the dkw
Supersport on the road at that time
modern bikes are lighter and more
refined everything from the chrome
radiator to the two mufflers is solid at
weighs 170 kilos all on its own but
since it's so powerful and rugged it's
perfect for use with a sidecar
so 170 kilos by itself and 240 with the
sidecar Wow whoa two-stroke engines like
the one of the super sports 600 tend to
overheat that's where the bikes radiator
comes in the chrome-plated streamlined
gas tank holds 14 litres that's enough
to travel about 200 kilometers even at
high speeds the sturdy tubular steel
frame is perfectly suited for use with a
sidecar advertisements from that period
describe the 600 as the greatest
motorcycle of its kind the 600
three-speed clutch and fish fin exhaust
system were pretty modern for the time
the bike could hit a top speed of 130
km/h without the sidecar
[Music]
that's why I took that Kristoff says
that the dkw is two-stroke engine had a
lot of power for a 1930s motorcycle 22
horsepower that doesn't sound like much
today but that's 600 CC displacement
water-cooled engine and flat piston
crowns were top-of-the-line features
back then dkw also used some of this
technology in the top-selling small car
of that period the f1 it was the first
German car with front-wheel drive a
resilient a dkw aircraft looks like
would it these are Tokina between hood
up in german ekw stands for a steam
powered vehicle the company started out
building accessories for steam engines
but by 1930 dkw is building 60,000
motorcycles a year
[Music]
Crysta points out that this model is the
rarest dkw bike of all only 300 of them
were built in 1930 Germany was in the
middle of the Great Depression and few
people could afford luxuries like
motorcycles a super sports 600 cost
about the same as a small car like the
Opel p4 production of the 600 was
canceled in 1933 after just three years
Christoph says it's a real shame
in 1934 dkw motorcycles started using
reverse scavenging exhaust technology in
all their engines
this allowed better engine performance
and improved fuel efficiency
Christophe says the dkw super sports 600
is a bike for real men big powerful and
built like a tank if you took a machine
like this on the road in the early 1930s
you were in for a real adventure and the
six hundreds engine served as the model
for the one used and the first German
passenger car with front-wheel drive the
dkw f1
up until the 1950s they hardly changed
the design of that car so you can say
that the dkw Super Sport 600 was
definitely a milestone in German
automotive history fans of the super
sports 600 referred to it today with
great reverence as the Cadillac of
motorcycles and perhaps the most
exciting dkw vehicle ever built
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]